- But your love is not like a square love.
- [Mark] Yeah, love doesn't
really come in the picture
for these girls, does it?
- Yeah, because I can't take
a big bag of love to the car lot,
or a big bag of love to
go pay my mortgage with,
you need a bag of money for that.
- [Mark] All right, Big Memphis.
- [Big Memphis] What's going on, my man?
- [Mark] Big Memphis. Where'd you grow up?
Where are you from? Let me guess.
- [Big Memphis] Memphis.
(both laugh)
- A long time a Memphician.
- [Mark] And tell me about your family.
You had both your parents
when you were young?
- Na.
- [Mark] Who raised you?
- Streets, man.
- [Mark] Where were mom and dad?
- Man, next question.
- [Mark] All right, next question?
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Mark] Understood. How
far did you go to school?
- 11th grade.
- [Mark] And the game
came to you at what age?
- About 17, 18.
- [Mark] 17, how did that happened?
- I've always been fascinated
by the players and the pimps, man.
They was always...
I liked those better than...
They were more cooler
than the drug dealers.
- [Mark] Yeah, when you were that age,
what options were there for you?
- Selling dope, robbing, pimping.
- [Mark] And the pimps just a little more-
- Yeah, and the work in it.
I sold dope, but it's just
my heart never was in it.
I liked the women.
Yeah, the women was more...
It was more funner with the women.
- [Mark] Did you have somebody teach you?
- As you step out there off the porch
and step off in the game,
you'll get cool with other
guys out on the track, man.
And you'll get the passing
game along with one another.
And that's how that'll go.
In any occupation, you're
gonna have a friend,
like I'm pretty sure you
got friend photographers.
And as you out there in
the same field every day,
there's gonna be some older guy
that's gonna take a
liking to you and going,
"Hey, youngling, this
how this go right here."
So, and that's how to go.
- [Mark] Yeah. And tell me
about your first girl you had.
- Oh, the first girl I ever had, man.
Wow, man, you take me back
a whole lot of hoes ago.
(laughs)
Yeah, the first hoe I ever had, man.
Wow. Yeah, Kim, a white
girl named Kim, man.
Yeah, uh huh.
- [Mark] And how'd that happen?
How did she come? How'd
you guys get together?
- Actually, she used to buy
dope from me, man, but...
She used to buy powder from me.
And every time she'd come,
she used to always have a big (indistinct)
But she was working at the strip club.
And she used to like me.
She's was always telling me,
"Man, you need to let me take care of you.
You need to let me take care of you."
And one day something had happened,
I think I had lost all
my money shooting dice.
And she came through.
I wanted to get some powder,
I didn't have no money to get some,
so she gave me the money to...
She front me some money
to get me some powder,
and she gave me some
money to put in my pocket.
Like $1,000 put in my pocket, man.
She told me, "Look, man
when you get through
it that last dopesack,
why don't you just come and
fuck with me al little bit?"
And man, I got with her, man,
and it's like I just never left.
You know what I'm saying?
And that one hoe, it just...
- [Mark] I hear that from
so many of the pimps,
that a girl took him under her wing
and showed them the ropes-
- Yeah, she was already
stripping, already in movement.
And she really liked me.
- [Mark] Yeah, that's
the key to it, isn't it?
- It seemed like the girls always...
They always, man, pull you in.
Well, a lot of times, a guy
gets turned on to the game.
Hoes get turned out, guys get turned on.
A lot of times, I've seen
weed guys get turned on,
or even the taxi driver
get turned on to the game.
You know what I'm saying?
Picking up hoes all the time.
He's real cool with the prostitutes.
He always out there on the track.
He's taking the bitches to dates.
And I've seen taxi drivers knock
guys for their hoes before.
Because see, a bitch will get to fucking
with the taxi driver,
and he's telling her,
"You ain't got to give me all your money."
You know what I'm saying?
"I take you where you gotta go for free."
And one day, her and her
dude might get into it,
and then, who is she gonna call?
She'll call the taxi driver,
and he'll let her know,
"Look, you ain't got to stay
over there at the hotel.
You can stay in my room. I
won't charge you for nothing."
And he'll let her stay over
there for a couple of days.
And I've seen taxi
drivers turn into pimps.
I've seen it go all kind of ways.
But a lot of the times,
it'll be a woman that
had turned a pimp on.
- [Mark] And here at Memphis,
it seems to be a really big thing.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Mark] The pimp and prostitute thing is-
- It's a big thing. Memphis
is known for pimps and hoes.
Memphis and Chicago.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Memphis and Chicago.
They're known for good pimping and hoeing.
- [Mark] And you just
came back from Las Vegas?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Mark] Tell me about
what you do in Vegas.
- I was just actually on
some businesses this time.
- [Mark] Okay, so you're not...
You're girls don't work Vegas?
- Yeah, of course, I work Vegas.
Vegas always pay me.
Vegas is a good city.
Vegas can give it to you,
or it can take it away from ya.
(Mark chuckles)
Yeah, it done both to me.
It's been good to me,
and it took away from me.
- [Mark] How many girls do you have?
- Two.
- [Mark] Two. Right, right.
And do you have sex with these girls?
- Man, I try my best to refrain from that.
If you could wake up and
see God every morning,
he wouldn't be that amazing to you.
So you gotta try to hold
that for rewards, man.
You know, you wanna try to hold that
for when they're doing
extra great. (laughs)
- [Mark] And what about drugs?
Are drugs part of that?
- No, I try to stay away from the drugs.
I like keeping clean,
but you know, out here in this world,
a lot of the women, they
gonna do something, man,
because they really have a...
Can you just imagine, man,
having sex with all those guys,
it's got to play some type
of mental stress on you.
- [Mark] So they kind of
need something to numb that?
- I mean, but I can understand it.
- [Mark] Oh, for sure.
- But I like them when they
don't have a drug problem.
Cause see, when they got drug problems,
it makes them get extra
conning and extra finesse.
And they do a lot of...
They tend to have a lot
of lies and a lot bullshit
when they get to messing
around on the drugs
versus when they don't do it.
You know, smoking a
little weed or something.
- [Mark] Yeah, but you almost
need to be drunk or high
to be doing this kind of work.
- I can imagine, man.
I could put myself in their shoes.
- [Mark] I know. What woman
sober is gonna say, yeah...
I've seen the guys these girls pick up.
Beautiful women pick up-
- Oh, my God.
- the bottom of the barrel guys.
- Oh my God.
- [Mark] Unbelievable.
- Oh, my God.
- [Mark] And you're just like... (laughs)
- You know, man, and I could just imagine.
I can imagine.
But you know, some of them,
nympho, some of them like it.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] It's a crazy thing.
- It's crazy, man. It's crazy.
But it's been going on
for a long time, man.
You know, the only...
For years, it was a victimless crime.
Nobody really even gave
a flying fuck about it.
It was a victimless
crime until these kids...
They started having these
teenagers and stuff like that.
That's when they start.
But for years, it was just
a public eyesore, you know?
But now, it's the public enemy number one.
- [Mark] Yeah, especially for the pimps.
- For the pimps. Oh man,
they'd probably beat me.
- [Mark] Yeah, even the cops have told me
they told me they don't want the girls,
they want the pimps.
- Yeah, they want the pimps, man.
They public enemy number one, man.
- [Mark] You've been arrested?
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Mark] What for?
- Promoting prostitution.
- [Mark] Yeah?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah man. You gotta (exhales) yeah.
- [Mark] You gotta be careful.
- You gotta be careful, man.
- [Mark] Don't go on
YouTube and talk about it.
- Man, and still be (laughs)
You gotta be careful, man.
- [Mark] What style of pimp are you?
Cause there's many
different styles, right?
- Yeah, you got many different styles.
- [Mark] Somebody introduced
me to you as a gorilla pimp.
- You know...
- [Mark] You're six foot
four. How much do you weigh?
- About 220. Yeah, about two 220. (laughs)
A lot of girls, man, you'll
run across a lot of girls, man
that they'd been through
so much in their life,
they'd be so mentally
scarred and so banged up
that they tough.
And they are...
Man, they love to fight.
They're rough, man.
Man, you meet some rough
girls out here, man,
that are (indistinct)
I met some rough chicks, man,
and they ain't scared of shit. (laugh)
They don't be scared of (indistinct)
A lot of them, they don't
feel like y'all together
unless she's fighting you,
or you're kicking her
on her ass or something.
It's crazy, man.
You meet a lot of girls, man.
It's like that, man.
You meet a lot of girls like that.
- [Mark] You've been doing this...
How old are you now, Matt?
- Man, I've been doing
this a long time, man,
over 20 years, man.
- [Mark] And what has it taught you
about human nature about women?
- Man, it's taught me that,
man, you either a trick
or you're a pimp, man.
You either give me your pussy
or where are you selling it?
It is one of those two
because when you really look at it,
everything a man do is to impress a woman.
I don't care how you look at it.
And see with a prostitute,
they really paying a woman to leave.
You're not paying it really for...
The sex is just a plus that come with it.
But you're really paying
her to never call you.
You don't got to see her
again and never nag you.
And to do what you wanted to
do to fulfill that sexually
and get out of your way,
which a wife, she's nagging.
So everything you do
is to impress a woman.
You work, you hustle,
everything you do is to impress a woman.
But with a prostitute,
you can just pay her,
have your way, and she
can go about her business.
It's taught me
that most men are tricks, man.
They love, pussy, man.
They'll do anything for some pussy, man.
- [Mark] What kind of crazy
behavior have you seen
from some of the tricks.
- Man, I've seen it all.
- [Mark] Cause they fall in
love with the girls quickly.
- I've seen it.
Some of them, I've seen
them fall in love with.
I seen some tricks,
man, that he's not happy
unless a bitch is stealing his money.
He lays it out just for
a bitch to steal it.
Some of them are not happy
unless they're getting
shitted or pissed on.
So it's just all kind of stuff.
Man, it's crazy, man.
But it is what it is
to where it went, man.
Yeah, that's what it is.
- [Mark] Does intimidation
or violence ever come
into the picture for you?
I mean, if a girl gets a
little headstrong or gets-
- [Big Memphis] It ain't about heads.
Like I said, a lot of them will start...
Especially when they
come in there drunk, man.
They'll come in just ready to fight.
You know, (laughs) they
come in ready to fight.
Man, you feel when they come in,
they lit, they ready to fight.
They got their shoes off, their wig off,
and they just ready to fight.
They got a knife, they (indistinct)
Yeah, you're gonna defend yourself.
I'm telling you, man, I'm telling you,
you run across some crazy women
and the streets make them...
Yeah. Yeah.
- [Mark] Yeah, I think alcohol or drugs,
it changes the personality.
- [Big Memphis] Alcohol,
a bad motherfucker, man.
- [Mark] There's some
girls I've interviewed
who your heart opens up,
and you just want to like
hug them and save them.
- [Big Memphis] Man!
- [Mark] But then three hours later...
- [Big Memphis] You go like this bitch
needs a fuckin (indistinct) (laughs)
- [Mark] She's a different person.
- [Big Memphis] Yeah, you're like,
"Man, shit man,"
she's got nine different
personalities on. (laughs)
- [Mark] So you ever been in love?
- [Big Memphis] No, no.
Man, I've been messing around
with prostitutes so long.
But I can have a love for...
The pimp love for a hoe is different.
You know, you have a business,
you've been around for a while.
Y'all doing a lot of stuff together.
You love what she doing for you.
Y'all having a good time traveling
the world, getting money.
So, but, you know, your love
is not like a square love.
- [Mark] Yeah, love doesn't really come in
the picture for these girls, does it?
- Yeah, because I can't
take a big bag of love
to the car lot
or a big bag of love to
go pay my mortgage with.
You need a bag of money for that.
- [Mark] Have any of these women ever turn
their lives around and
lived a square life.
- Yeah. And I have where
some of them will come back.
They'll call three,
four, five years later.
It's just not working out.
I was just wondering
if you're still in the
game and da-da-da-da.
- Yeah, I'm still in there,
baby. You know what I'm saying?
And they wanna get with it,
you know, repeat offenders.
- [Mark] Hmm. And stealing
from tricks is part
of the game for a lot
of these girls, right?
- Yeah, a lot of them
steal, yeah, yeah, yeah.
A lot of them steal.
- [Mark] They're hustlers.
- Yeah, a lot of them,
they're gonna steal.
- [Mark] What kind of girl...
What personality traits do you look for?
What qualities?
- Man, I'm looking for a
smart, go-getter, a listener.
That's what I'm really looking for, man.
- [Mark] Some of these
girls are just not cut out
for this kind of work.
- Some of them are not.
And when they're not cut out,
you just gotta let them go.
You know, because
messing around with them,
you have a human trafficking charge.
It'll cost you, man,
so if it ain't working,
just let them go.
- [Mark] Yeah. And do you have kids?
- Yeah, I got two sons.
- [Mark] You raised them?
- Yeah, they grown. My
son, they're grown, man.
They grown.
- [Mark] They're
following dad's footsteps?
- Nah, nah, they not, actually.
- [Mark] They know what dad does?
- Yeah. They know.
- [Mark] What do they think of that?
- They think it's the greatest thing.
(both laugh)
They think their dad is cool.
- [Mark] So do you think
the prostitutes relationship
with a pimp is based on like recreating
what she had with her father, which was-
- A lot of them are looking
for the father syndrome.
- [Mark] They call you guys, daddy?
- Yeah. Well, that's where it comes from
because of the instructions
that you give them,
what you're teaching them, you know?
But in a lot of them, I
don't care what they call me,
as long as they don't call me bro.
I ain't really hung up
on the you got to call me daddy thing.
When it just happens, it flows better
because I called them mom, "Hey, mom."
So dad just kind of
flows off their tongue.
And once they learning with you
and learning from you,
and you're teaching them
a lot of good stuff, man,
you know, you're the
first flight they been on,
first time they've done
a lot of things, man,
so they tend to call you
daddy from that respect.
Just out of respect, man.
- [Mark] So a girl brings
you 100% of her money?
- I would hope so. (laughs)
- [Mark] And then what does she get?
- Whatever she needs.
Whatever she needs, man.
Ain't no what she can't have.
- [Mark] What an honest guess
at what these girls make a night?
Because I hear all kinds
of exaggerated amounts.
- You really can't. It's hard
to say, man, it's hard to say.
I try not to put a cap code on it, man.
So you really just give
it all you got, you know?
- [Mark] But here in Memphis,
if a guy was to pick up
a girl for like an hour
of fun with her, what
would that cost a guy?
- $100, $150.
- [Mark] Yeah?
- Yeah, $100, $150.
- [Mark] And so she'll end up
doing this three, four, five,
six, seven, eight times a day?
- Yeah. If it's rolling.
If it's going good, yeah.
Yeah, if it's going good.
Yeah, I like...
You got some good cities that
they give it up real good,
but yeah, if they're coming
back to back like that,
she's gonna get them.
- [Mark] And do you ever feel any guilt
or anything about having
these girls do this for you,
so you can just sit back
and collect the money?
- No, no, no. They was
already in the mix now,
so no.
- [Mark] Do you feel like
you provide a service?
- I mean-
- [Mark] You give them guidance?
- Yeah, you give them
guidance, you give her...
When she first met ya, everything
she had was all in a bind,
everything she owned was in a CVS bag.
Now she got...
She can't even count her bags.
She can't even count her heels.
She didn't even know how to eat lobsters.
Now she's eating lobsters (indistinct)
so I feel like you show them
this is how it's supposed
to be done right here.
- [Mark] Yeah, and what's
the most important lesson
you've learned?
- [Big Memphis] At the end of the day,
the only thing that matters
is what the county is, man.
You know, what the county
is all that matters
at the end of the day, man.
- [Mark] Alright, Big Memphis.
- Man, it's been a pleasure, man.
- [Mark] Thank you so much
for sharing your story.
- It's been a pleasure, my man.
- [Mark] I wish you the
best of luck out there.
- [Big Memphis] You too, my man.
- [Mark] Take care of your girls.
- [Big Memphis] But it's
been a pleasure, my man